in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Zach
angeline are here hey guys how are you
hey how are you
welcome welcome Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas where are you guys from
Pensacola Florida and we'll welcome to
the cold north my goodness it's hard to
believe Nashville is the cold north but
you're here so here to do a debt free
scream yes we are how much have you guys
paid off 32,000 all right how long did
that take about 12 months good for you
and your range of income we started off
at about 60 and ended up right at 80 Wow
how'd you get that much of a raise in
one year busting it lots of sacrifice
that old fine hard work thing yeah oh my
goodness so what kind of debt was the 32
thousand a little of everything we had
car debt we had a 401 k loan which we
used to buy a car um we paid off a
medical bill so they didn't repossess
our daughter um let's see we financed a
couple of cellphones and we I could find
her yeah computer you guys were just
kind of normal
yeah unfortunately oh my gosh Wow so
what happened 12 months ago they put you
on this journey to get out of debt oh
well we moved to Pensacola in May and
then things just started spiraling out
of control
and we just our everything got really
tight really quick mm-hmm so you know is
one of those things and I didn't know
what to do so I actually I just googled
how to get out of debt and your name
popped up there it is just like that you
know so you're stressed out freaked out
there's no room in the budget there's no
room in the life and so you're like I
got to get some help and Google pops us
up yep there you go just like that then
what'd you do then I downloaded a couple
of podcast and I heard you start talking
about every dollar at the time and then
then you start talking about financial
piece and and so then we ended up
enrolling in a class
and looked it up and went ahead and you
know we went to a couple of classes and
you know at the time she just thought I
was a kook still and I did and so then
we just I went to the couple classes and
was trying to figure out how in the
world am I going to come up with 93
bucks to pay for a class especially
since I gone to college with a business
degree and you know the traditional yes
learning there so we did our first every
dollar budget and at the time I had
actually just recently accepted Christ
and so oh excuse me but uh so initially
we started you know tithing aspect of
things and there was exactly three
hundred ninety three dollars what was
the extra three out of the ninety three
above three hundred so 300 extra the
three hundred at the time was um what
the ten percent would have been oh yeah
oh that's like in the guys yeah guys
like yelling at you yeah in the numbers
that's funny so at that point Jillian
did you decide we're going I was going
to follow him wherever he led you know
he is the provider her family he is the
head of our household so I was gonna
jump in with both feet and we're gonna
do it together mm-hmm
whatever it took whatever sacrifice we
had to make and I came from a family
where it was not a big deal to have
mountains of bills but I wanted
something different for our kids I
wanted something different for us so
that brought this to me and I said okay
you know I don't understand it I don't
really understand why you want to do it
but let's let's just do it let's just
jump in and do it
so you started going to the class
together then we did okay at our church
on and so at what point and going
through the class during that nine weeks
did julene did you kind of go okay I get
it now this is starting to work I see it
I think it was probably halfway through
the class and I started to see we were
obviously doing our debt snowball so I
started to see things
the way that he did mmm how we were able
to pay things down and get rid of that
dead and then we were able to put more
money to our other debt and I started to
see the purse strings loosen a little
bit so I was like okay okay I understand
now so we just full speed ahead whatever
we had to do the more you understand it
and the more you believe the further on
the gas pedal you step exactly you know
you know it was a team thing it you know
we had to do it together he's the one
that goes to work every day he's the one
that brings in the Paycheck I'm a
stay-at-home mom so I had to find ways
to manage the things within our house
all the things that I could control
gotcha okay so we're in this process did
you accept Christ just before so just
before you start the class well I
started the class or I found the class
after I started listening to the podcast
laboum and we were we were really
thinking selfishly and how I justified
it to join originally was hey it's 93
dollars
mm-hmm and we get a babysitter for nine
weeks yeah are you look like she was
what five months older [ __ ] yeah she
was she was little so wait a minute or V
him to financial Charlie you were what
you were living in an elevator really an
RV when we started the class part of our
we were so broke we couldn't afford it
so we actually my parents were gracious
enough they'd let us borrow their RV for
six months okay yeah so we lived in an
RV with two little rascals for six
months oh my lord he said we were like
let's do this class we have a free baby
so what I'm trying to figure out is we
went over there the first time to go to
the class at that point you weren't
walking with God no so we went to go to
the class and just before before to see
if we trusted the people in the nursery
to watch our kids mhm
we went one Sunday ah and then that
Sunday is when the walls come crap yep
very I'm going down very cool which
church is this it's all about just very
neat good job guys all right fun very
fun that's neat so a whole lot of stuff
changed in your life during this
12-month adventure yeah everything
changed a lot Wow very cool so you got a
place
now you're out of the RV oh yeah and you
got a second baby now yeah we had the
second baby whenever we moved to
Pensacola already oh yeah and we
actually we got another one that'll be
here next year so right well very fun
yeah good times very cool so what is the
key to getting out of debt now that
you've done it
um sacrifice um education yeah what
Sharon always says it you have to be on
the same page if you're not then it's
not gonna work well and definitely the
budget so yes up for us every dollar we
do every dollar every month every single
month we sit down at the beginning of
every month you do it on your phones we
do okay mm-hmm very cool so the she's
not too keen on carrying a lot of cash
so we just used the debit card and so it
was really easy for her to when she was
at the grocery store whatever you say
all right at two hundred ninety six
dollars left all right now let's see
what I can do with it so Wow
yeah every dollar really helps with that
tremendous got the right there in your
hand it's you're carrying around
everything with you when you get your
your budget in your phone it's just neat
very cool well congratulations you too
I'm very proud of you thank you a lot of
wonderful life change what a great
Christmas you're going to have this year
yes what a different kind of a place to
be yeah walking with Christ and
debt-free and babies everywhere you're
out of the RV life is good yes this is
good I'm proud of you guys well we've
got a copy of Chris Hogan's book retire
inspired which is a number one
bestseller and that'll be your next
chapter we want you to come back on the
end of your millionaire talk tell us how
you became a millionaire that's in the
works okay I get on there already did
the math and use the Chris Hogan tool
and it shows I should we should be there
right at age 50 all right well you'll
probably be there before then then okay
and the girls names and ages are what
Giuliana is 20 months and Cheyenne is
three okay very cool good all right Zach
and Jolene Cheyenne and Julianna $32,000
paid off in 12 months making 60 to 80
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream ready scream want a scream
alright one two three where
ah way to go you guys very very well
done
merry Christmas to you Wow if you ever
thought about being a Financial Peace
University coordinator I think you just
heard why churches teach Financial Peace
University right then man that's
powerful this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]